Question 1 - Zecare asks, What is Hiroshi
Sato doing if he’s supposed to be back in
book 4?
Question 2 - Rose Lily asks, will Toph be
the one to help Korra out of her funk?
Question 3 - jose cose asks, do you think
Toph will reunite with her daughters?
Question 4 - Andre asks, Do you think we’ll
see Suki from Last Airbender?
(map already filled in at Kyoshi Island)
Question 5 - Evil Grave asks, what do you
think Toph has been doing in the swamps this
whole time?
Question 6 - D.R.
Dinkins asks, do you think we’ll get a Last
Airbender moment with Zuko, Toph
and Katara?
Question 7 - Alan asks, do you think that
Swamp is the same one Aang had visions of
Toph for the first time?
Question 8 - mink v 3 asks, I
hope they elaborate on Kuvira because she
doesn’t seem as powerful as Zaheer
or Amon?
Question 9 - Ryan asks, do you think we’ll
ever see middle aged Katara or Zuko in a flashback,
so far we’ve only seen
them
in people’s pictures?
Question 10 - commbold asks, do you think
Korra’s hallucinations are just a mental
thing with her or was the avatar spirit itself
poisoned?
Question 11 - Jake asks, how did
you interpret the first scene of Korra staring
into the broken mirror then healing herself
in
the sink?
Question 12 - Jomar asks, why wasn’t Vaatu
in the big tree when Korra went to the spirit
world?
Winner - Tommy Hutchinson